grand theft auto 5 is consistently one
of the best-selling games each week
almost 10 years after it was originally
released yeah bet that makes you feel
old because it certainly does me i
remember watching the announcement
trailer for gta 5 back when i was in
college uh excuse me while i have a
michael like midlife crisis here i'm i'm
i'm gonna need some hot coffee however
like me gta 5 may be showing its age
because we're finally starting to get
our first hints of grand theft auto 6.
with rockstar recently confirming that
development of the game is quote well
underway and rumors constantly swirling
about new characters and the game's
location yet while gta 5 and gta online
remain popular to this day it's clear
after the tragic launch of grand theft
auto the trilogy definitive edition that
even the mightiest of video game
franchises can't rest on its laurels so
i put together my list of what i want
for the franchise that skipped an entire
generation of consoles to do in order to
update itself for today
number one a new setting but not in the
present day okay i'm going to start off
my list a little bit controversially
because some people just want to see the
comments section burn while it has not
been confirmed a lot of rumors and
unconfirmed leaks have pointed to gta 6
set to take a return to the seminole by
city the franchise has passed each
version of miami florida and many fans
have actually been excited to possibly
find themselves back in the world of the
80s style gangsters pastel suits and
palm trees however some fans such as
myself have never really been beach
people and even more so think it's time
for the series to branch out from
constantly returning to old haunts and
try something new what would a chicago
new orleans or austin feel like in the
twisted world of grand theft auto or
even further how about stepping outside
of the united states and give us a look
at somewhere like london and yes i know
the series has actually gone there
before but it would be cool to actually
see gta's version of london in three
dimensions this time however one thing
the series should steal from vice city
is a non-present day setting vice city's
80s vibe is what helped make that entry
stand out so perhaps a game set in the
70s or 90s could also lend this new
installment a much needed sense of style
and identity plus if it's set during the
90s we could maybe bring pogs back into
style and who doesn't want pogs to
return
number two multiple protagonists yeah i
know i must hate myself because i'm
doubling down on the controversial
choices here one of the most polarizing
aspects of gta 5 was its choice to
feature multiple protagonists in its
main story and certainly this decision
came with mixed results in terms of the
actual plot however for me i think it
actually lent a truly unique ability for
the game to make the world feel more
alive i adored jumping between different
characters to just see what each of them
was doing when i returned to them like
michael doing yoga in his fancy house or
franklin walking the streets of downtown
or
whatever the hell trevor was up to me
the psycho no
you are the craziest chick i've ever met
i love you you're thin you're
irrationally angry nothing you say makes
any sense you are
completely have no control of your
emotions we have nothing in common oh
baby we're made for each other prove it
it instantly put you into the feel of
each character to get to see their
varied ways of existing within the city
with a tighter narrative this varied
perspective could help give the game's
story some much needed lengths and yet
continue to evolve the risks taken in
gta 5 without back pedaling on them hell
you could even marry this idea with the
concept of different time zones from my
last entry with each character possibly
living in a different time period of the
same city allowing for the series to
truly take a big risk with the formula
and show off the rockstar team's
creative skill
number three a female protagonist this
one should hopefully not be a shock to
anybody despite being one of the oldest
and biggest gaming franchises that's
still thriving grand theft auto has
never centered a female playable
character in any of its mainline games
in fact
it's kind of an understatement to say
that grand theft auto hasn't really been
known to treat women uh
well let's just say what kind of [ __ ]
animal do you take me for no i didn't
kill him
but i did kidnap his wife oh no
oh [ __ ] and while that may have been
overlooked in previous entries it would
be deeply disappointing for a new
iteration to continue that trend but
even more so i don't want the game to
just add a female protagonist just for
the sake of it just to you know mark off
that checkbox but i actually think it
would inject a much needed storytelling
vibrancy to see a woman within the
criminal world of the grand theft auto
games most women in gangster types of
storylines get relegated to the role of
wife or girlfriend so it would actually
allow the series to add a fresh twist to
a somewhat stale genre what would it be
like for a woman to rise to prominence
in the mob world or hell why not feature
a woman who gets to be as over-the-top
bonkers as trevor was in gta 5. having a
woman yank herself into the driver's
seat of the franchise could be a cool
way to see this world with fresh eyes
number four a stronger narrative while
the characters of grand theft auto games
have consistently been their strength
its plot sadly has not been while it was
interesting to see trevor's antics or
michael's midlife crisis in grand theft
auto 5 the actual story descended into a
convoluted mess of conspiracies and
heists the same thing happened in grand
theft auto 4 with nico being a fairly
intriguing lead left to languish in a
pretty standard tale
life is complicated i
i never thought i'd live like this
no
when the war came i did bad things and
after the war i thought nothing of doing
bad things in fact to my mind san
andreas is the only game in the series
to ever nail telling a truly engaging
narrative front to back yet it's clear
that rockstar can tell a strong
narrative with the red dead redemption
games being some of the most unique and
memorable stories of the past few
generations of gaming so why not bring
that same level of craft to the grand
theft auto series and truly tell a story
worthy of the game's legacy
but with that said that brings me to
number five more grounded insanity look
we all know that the grand theft auto
games can get pretty bonkers especially
when you play around in the game's
sandbox i mean personally my favorite
thing to do playing grand theft auto
growing up was to use cheat codes to
become invincible spawn a rocket
launcher and then just start shooting
everything that moved until an army of
tanks showed up and that same level of
off the wall antics has continued into
grand theft auto online yet in the year
since grand theft auto 5's release the
saints row series has come and gone and
possibly may even come back again and
over the course of that franchise it
went from lighthearted parody of the
grand theft auto games to straight-up
alien invasion superhero antics it kind
of feels like the era of parody in these
types of games reached its zenith a few
years ago so for grand theft auto 6
while i would still want to have those
over the top moments here and there
lending the story a more grounded
sensibility overall may be the way to go
so that when those bigger moments do
happen they feel like true climaxes
instead of tired parody
number six a more lived in world open
world games have really evolved in the
years since grand theft auto 5 released
and while the more aimless feel may have
been acceptable in 2013 it's certainly
showing its age in 2022 games like red
dead or the witcher or the recently
released elden ring have shown that it's
possible to have a large sprawling world
that also still feels like they exist
beyond just being a playground for your
player character having npcs live their
own lives and there being just generally
more casual things to do around the
world is a must for a new gta in fact we
should also see more interior locations
too ensuring that the gta world doesn't
just feel like one big outdoor area with
some buildings in it to navigate around
but a true living breathing city
number seven improved fighting mechanics
okay so i'm not asking for the grand
theft auto games to become sifu or
anything like that because the series
gameplay focus should always remain on
its guns yet i think we can all kind of
admit that punching in grand theft auto
games has never really felt fun outside
of maybe san andreas one of the best
things grand theft auto 6 could do is
actually make punching out random
pedestrians on the street feel
oh so so satisfying adding in a few
small fighting mechanics could go a long
way to making the gameplay feel fresh
number eight rpg light elements now i
don't want gta to go all assassin's
creed on us and turn away from its
arcade roots into a more grounded rpg
however one fun element of san andreas
was its light rpg elements allowing you
to really craft your character in your
own unique way staying fit or building
up stats was a lot of fun and in return
to some of those elements could be a
cool way to really build upon previous
entries in the franchise plus being
honest i'll probably just end up only
eating fast food like i do in real life
good talk radio it goes without saying
that any grand theft auto game worth
itself should feature an iconic
soundtrack however my personal favorite
thing in any grand theft auto game has
got to be the talk radio channels i have
a ton of fond memories of listening to
the hilariously over the top npr station
while playing liberty city stories on my
psp you've alienated all your friends
huh have you yeah mostly because i
listen to your show all the time and i
tell people they should live by your
advice oh yeah i did own a psp and
actually i still have it also by the way
i dug this out for this little bit in
this video and i didn't check what was
inside it and i found that i had a copy
of spider-man 2 in it like the movie not
the game do you all remember when we
were told that we would be watching
movies on this thing like umd's are the
way of the future uh the past is weird
but coincidentally speaking of
spider-man games like marvel spider-man
and its spin-off miles morales have
continued this talk radio trend with j
jonah jameson's rant and conspiracy fuel
podcast being one of the most fun
world-building elements of those games
people i always thought spider-man was a
few geese sort of a gaggle but this
confirms it as if that atrocious white
spider wasn't enough i've had repeated
sightings of him
in a new outfit some sort of punk rock
inspired thing that makes sane people
want to tear out their eyeballs with a
rusty spoon sadly though the talk radio
shows of grand theft auto 5 were fairly
lackluster so it would behoove any new
entry of the grand theft auto franchise
to help restore the series glory days
and bring us some new talk shows single
player dlc yeah i know i'm probably
getting a little bit ahead of myself
thinking about dlc before the main game
is even out but i think gta 5 fans have
all felt the disappointment at the lack
of single player additional content for
the game rather given the cash cow that
is gta online rockstar has instead
focused mainly on building out its
multiplayer component instead while
there have been some single-player
missions here and there for gta like the
recent franklin story missions they felt
few and far between and more like side
quests than true big additions to the
gta world yet while single player dlc
may not be as money generating as its
online counterparts some of grand theft
auto 4's best moments came from its dlc
additions the ballad of gay tony and the
lost and the damned so in addition to
just a greater focus on single player in
the main game it would be a welcome
return to form for gta 6 to give us even
more bonkers and risk taking side
stories in additional dlc
that's my list for what i want in grand
theft auto 6 but i know a lot of my
choices were probably let's just say
divisive so i'd love to hear your
thoughts below would you rather return
to vice city do you think the franchise
should actually go even more over the
top instead and what else would you like
to see i'd love to hear all that down in
the comments below and don't forget to
like and subscribe to this channel for
more gta coverage as it comes out and if
you can't wait you can check out our
rankings for all the grand theft auto
games but until then i am going to start
replaying vice city stories on my psp
and i thank you so much for watching
[Music]